- Okay.
Hey and welcome to our talk.
What's new in AWS
full-stack app development.
My name is Mark and with me
is my co-presenter, Salih.
We are both based out of Berlin
and we have a background
in full-stack development
and that's probably
what brought us here to
have that talk with you.
(attendees chattering)
- So, what you will see today
is that I'm talking about what's new
in full-stack development obviously,
because that's the thing in its talk.
And obviously, one of the biggest changes
that happened in the last few years
is how generative AI is being
used during development.
And full-stack development
is not any different.
And because we don't want
to make this a sales show
and telling you that GenAI is
solving all of your problems,
we will go and have a
honest checkpoint with you.
So, where the gaps are, what GenAI can do,
where it doesn't do well,
and what we can do about it.
And to make the things real,
we will have a live demo with Salih.
So, he is as brave as
it can be and he will go
and is coding live for
you in app on the stage.
(attendees chattering)
- So, let me see. Whoop.
Let me see
(Salih chuckles)
who we have here today.
So, who of you would identify
as a full-stack developer?
Please raise your hands.
(attendees chattering)
- Okay. That's pretty much majority.
Nice, nice.
I think you found the right talk.
And how many of you are
using GenAI tools day-to-day
to do software development?
(attendees chattering)
- Okay, that's a bit less.
Maybe we can change that a little bit.
And then, now, tell me who
of you use generative AI
and checking it in right away to prod
without checking it twice or triple?
(attendees chattering)
- Okay, that's what I thought.
Nobody is doing that and
I'm very happy about that.
So, what's a full-stack developer?
For me, a full-stack developer
is handing the entire stack,
frontend, backend, databases.
And obviously, most of you will be able
to just code an idea up into prod
and actually have it right away.
So, who of you are full-stack developers
because the team is small
or there maybe solo
running their own startup?
Who of you is actually
a full-stack developer
because the circumstances are like that?
(attendees chattering)
- Yes. Okay.
And for me, full-stack development
has something beauty in it.
It is a very pragmatic approach.
It's about velocity and ownership.
So, because you are usually alone
on building your application
and you can actually build everything
from the backend to the frontend,
you have an idea, you can
bring it all the way through,
this is what is the
prototype of an entrepreneur.
So, a single person with a great idea
and a great mind and great
skills can build it all.
But while you have all of this control,
it also comes at a certain cost.
So, you need to deal
with a lot of complexity.
So, most of the things
that you're dealing with and juggling,
those things are a mental burden.
You have to deal
with all the different things
that might break in a night.
You have to deal with
security vulnerabilities
that you need to keep track of.
Oh, this stack now has a new update
and there's new vulnerability found.
And is my app really
working all the way through?
And all of a sudden, you are on TV
or I don't know, some social media outlet,
and does it scale?
And all of that, you have to deal with
but it's not something that
you will enjoy all the time.
And in the last year, the nature
of that complexity shifted.
It's not that GenAI source all of that.
It's more that the complexity shifted
into a different style of
dealing with the complexity.
(attendees chattering)
- So, what do you need as
a full-stack developer?
(attendees chattering)
- So, you have to deal with hosting.
So, you have to deal with
the content delivery network,
with your DNS records,
you have Infrastructure as Code hopefully,
because you're not doing ClickOps.
You have to deal with your
API gateway configuration,
your compute, your database,
your storage, your
authentication, all of it.
And not only that but
you also have a pager
because between all of
those integration points
that you have to deal with,
there might also be a little bit
of business logic that
you need to implement
to actually make that app real.
And at least in my time
as a full-stack developer,
things usually break at
3:00 AM in the morning
when you really don't expect that
or on a Sunday afternoon
when you're out there with your kids.
So, dealing with all of those things
(attendees chattering)
- is a lot on your plate.
And GenAI, in the last two years,
actually gave you a boost, right?
So, you're much more productive,
you get a lot more things done,
but faster is not always better.
So, how I see GenAI,
and I don't know if this is my fault,
at least it comes to mind,
for me, GenAI is the
fastest keyboard on earth.
But it's not really more than that.
There's still someone
that needs to know what
you want to achieve.
GenAI usually does not have an intent.
It does not have an objective to reach.
It is something that
brings you fast forward
and it creates very
confidently a lot of code.
And most of the time, the code is correct,
but do you know if it is
having the best practices?
Does it give you secure components?
So, you have this fast pace
now that you need to deal with
and fast also means a lot more complexity
in understanding that.
(attendees chattering)
- And if you remember
in the last 20 years,
when we had to deal with
complex integration projects,
there were frameworks
that helped us through it
and that's not any different today.
So, if you think about Amplify,
which is a full-stack
application framework from AWS,
it has comprehensive service covering,
it has global hosting,
TypeScript for full-stack development,
and it gives you CI/CD pipelines,
it gives you a sandbox,
it gives you UI building components,
and all of them fit very well together.
And it lets you use CDK to
define your infrastructure
and expand that infrastructure
with escape hatches
where Amplify doesn't have a
component for you right away.
And what's new is we also put some effort
into making it easier for Kiro, Cursor,
or your preferred AI
tool to actually use it.
(attendees chattering)
- So, the cool thing about Amplify
is it's outside for seven years or so
and it is used globally in
hundreds of thousands of apps.
So, all the components that
are defined in Amplify,
they actually work, they're battle-tested.
We have fixed all the bugs
and we keep it current.
And now, if you use GenAI,
the problem that most of us have seen
is if you ask it to create you a database,
it goes with Python code and Bota3
and gives you all the SDK codes required
to actually set up your database.
(attendees chattering)
- And that might not be what you want.
And it might also not
give you guidance on,
if you want to use Aurora
database or DynamoDB.
Obviously, I always want a Dynamo,
but that might not be the right thing
for your specific use case.
And to get your specific use
case there is not so easy.
It is a lot of prompting
that is happening.
So, Amplify is helping you
with giving you predefined
constructs that you can base on
and that helps the AI
to actually limit the
scope of possibilities,
which then also gives you
a lot less code that you have to review.
So, Amplify, as I said,
is already out there for a long time.
And just alone this year, we
have built 31 major features
and that was like basically
multiple deployments
of new things every month.
So, to just pick out a few CDK,
we integrated all across Amplify.
And one thing that we integrated this year
was the CDK toolkit
library, which allows you
to programmatically
using CDK under the hood.
And what it gives you is
full abstractions of L2
and L3 constructs that you can use,
and CDK promises
to have the AWS best practices built-in
so that you can rely on that
to be the right thing
that you want to use.
So, the other thing
that we built quite heavily
on was storage browser.
So, all the pink ones here.
Storage browser is basically a
micro site that you can embed
and it helps you to host or
to manage your files on S3.
It gives you permissions,
it gives you download capabilities
with multi-file downloads,
thumbnails, custom
validation for file uploads.
You can share them privately
or with a certain group.
So, you have really enterprise control
over what's needed in your file storage.
(attendees chattering)
- And the cool thing about that
is you don't have to build that
with custom code and GenAI.
You can just drop in that one
and you know that you
have all the capabilities
that you require.
But we wouldn't be AWS
if security would not be our prime focus.
And that's the one that also
is scaring most people off
when it comes to GenAI.
Am I really sure that all the codes
is being generated is secure?
(attendees chattering)
- I have some hard time sometime
to review all of the codes
that is being reviewed,
that's being generated.
So, if you can see there's a drumbeat
of security-related features
that we built into Amplify is here.
There was web application
firewall integration,
there's Passkey support,
which helps it to log in as a customer.
And one thing that probably
is a very tedious task is
refresh token rotation.
So, if any one of you ever had certificate
that ran out of time and
just broke in a moment,
it's a lot of hassle to
actually get that back up.
And I have never seen
that there is a perfect
way to deal with that
and it's something that just
requires a lot of automation
and consciousness about
that to be the case.
We also released a email MFA.
If you're like me,
you don't like to give your
phone number to any website
just for logins, email MFA might
be a way to deal with that.
The last thing I would like to highlight
as something that, is Svelte support.
Svelte is not just yet
another JavaScript framework
that we integrated in Amplify,
it was done by the community.
So, Amplify is an open
source community project
and we are super happy
with our community contributing to it.
And when Svelte became
famous, there were people
that were actually saying that,
"Oh, I would really like to
use Svelte within Amplify,"
because they already had mobile
applications with Amplify
and on the websites,
they wanted to use Svelte
for whatever reason, "because I liked it."
And so, I said, okay, let's
help and get that out there.
And now, Svelte is fully
supported in Amplify
and I think it's something
that we should continue doing.
(attendees chattering)
- And I know there's a lot
going on on that slide,
but those are not random features.
So, our mental model about
Amplify is that we want
to build you a framework
that is a rock solid foundation
for production-grade apps.
And all of those things
that we have built in,
were also with the mindset of, okay,
so if you want to be part
of this new GenAI wave
where people are using more
and more things like Kiro, Lovable,
any vibe coding platforms,
we need to make sure
that the things that are
really hard to get right
are built into the framework
so that GenAI doesn't have to guess it.
And all of what we have built
here actually brings us closer
to a framework that can
be easier accessible by AI
because it does not have to guess
how certain things have to be done.
Token rotation is something
I don't want to have custom code for.
I would like to know
that this was tested all the
way through in production
and I can trust.
So, we have done some
strategic investments
into what would GenAI
need from a framework
to actually make things
better for customers.
(attendees chattering)
- So, how is Amplify with GenAI?
So, how many of you
are using Cursor, Kiro,
(attendees chattering)
- or any of those tools?
Okay, it's a few.
You should try it.
It's actually pretty amazing.
Even I as a manager now can code again,
which is pretty cool to see.
So, many, many times when
I was creating software
with one of those GenAI tools,
(attendees chattering)
- the suggestions were
going in the right direction
but they were not exactly
matching my intent.
So, there's a lot of context in my mind
of what I want to build,
and the only way that I can transfer it
into a generic GenAI tool is I prompt.
And I don't know if you have tried
but I ran into doomprompting
over and over again
because it just didn't get
it right in the first place
and then I iterated over it,
and at some point, I just gave up,
and said okay, let me do it myself.
So, if you ever experienced
that, this is not great.
So, you feel at some point like,
okay, is this GenAI thing really real?
Does it really help me?
And it feels so tedious
because why do I need to
explain all of those things?
It should be more obvious
what has to happen.
But GenAI does not have the context
of your last two years of development.
It does not know what Peter did last week
and it does not know
what was discussed in
your last sprint planning.
And yes, you can maybe have
something that is listening
to all of your
conversation, put it all in,
but in the context, it's too
big and doesn't work either.
So, let's go back to the first principles.
So, how do we get into a place
where GenAI knows what it needs to know
to make proper choices
in your software development lifecycle.
So, I hope no one of you
ever had to build your own JSON parser
because the Ivory's out there.
So, GenAI, I should not
try to reinvent the wheel
and build everything from scratch,
but using things that
are already already made.
So, last year,
the Stack Overflow survey said that 84%
of developers were using
GenAI on a daily basis
or intended to do so.
I guess this year, it's even higher.
And I didn't check.
The benefits are real.
So, you can get a lot more
things done much faster,
but it also sometimes
is tedious, as I said.
And so, now, what happened this year
is that we try to close
the gap on the context
that the GenAI needs to have
to actually make proper decisions
on what needs to happen.
And one emerging technology
in this year was the
model context protocol.
Model context protocol is a way
that I can define a server for GenAI
that it can actually ask certain things.
So, how do I do this?
I have the following task.
Is there any best
practices or documentation
that I might need to pull
into my context window?
And we have released a model
context protocol server called AWS MCP.
And that one embodies
the documentation of AWS,
all the different, I mean, we
have a lot of documentation,
not only like the main documentation
but a lot of outlets,
blog posts and everything, best practices.
And the coolest thing about MCP,
it's not only documentation,
it's not like RAG,
it also gives you the ability
to define workflows in a
specific predefined manner.
It's called SOPs, like
standard operating procedures.
So, if you want to create a database,
it does it in a certain way
so that it follows best practices.
So, use CDK under the hood,
have a certain configuration there,
make sure that it's secure,
that your S3 buckets
are not publicly
available, stuff like that.
All of those things that otherwise,
you might need to go through
tedious prompt cycles
are already there
and the model can take the
right choices from the get-go.
So, the problem that we have seen
is that if you take a generic GenAI tool,
only in 10% of the cases,
it was creating production-ready software.
So, most of the time, it
compiled, it actually worked,
but all the integrated details
that you want to have in this code
and that you would choose directly,
they were not there, they
were not configured correctly,
they missed maybe the index
for your DynamoDB table.
They choose Aurora over Dynamo,
or vice versa, no matter what it is.
And that's why you had to iterate over it.
With MCP, we can make sure
that the choices are more valid
and we have created a lot more knowledge,
especially for Amplify as a framework
so that it picks up things
that are already made.
And the same for CDK, so
that CDK cloud formation
and Amplify are no strangers
to your tool if you use that MCP.
And with that, I would
like to give over to Salih
who will go a bit deeper into that
and also makes it a bit more real
with like a proper live demo.
- Let's see. (chuckles)
Thank you. (clears throat)
Thank you very much, Mark.
All right.
So, today, we will talk about our journey
from going from the vibe
into something that is real.
GenAI, from the hands that I see,
GenAI is still a bit of a
thing that we are afraid of,
but we have to understand
that this is just a tool that
is making our lives easier.
To use this tool, AWS
actually offered you a lot
of different options like
Mark said earlier on.
For example, we had Knowledge
MCP that was allowing you
to get some best practices
or example codes, and so on.
We had API that was
allowing you to use AWS CLI
to get any information from your account
so it was doing the necessary
calls for your CLI command.
We also had frontend MCP
that was allowing you
to build a frontend application with React
and CDK in the most
effective way possible.
And we had the IaC and
Serverless MCPs as well
that was allowing you to
use these AI agentic IDs
or coding tools to move forward.
And maybe you heard, maybe you heard not,
we released in the middle of July, Kiro.
Kiro is the agentic ID
that is allowing you to not only vibe code
but also create spec-driven developments,
so you tell what you want from it
and it actually brings it
into a more structured way.
Today, one more time,
I'm happy to announce AWS MCP.
AWS MCP is there
to bring the Knowledge MCP that we have
and the API MCP and many
others all together.
These MCPs are giving you a chance
to create your full-stack applications
through the procedures that
we already created for you.
We have created more than
30 different procedures
to know what to do
for having the best for your
agents to build an application.
For example, in case you wanna
search for documentation,
you don't need to add the
documentation MCP anymore.
You still can but you don't have to.
You now, you can use AWS MCP to call that.
Do you want to get some information
about deploying an app to Amplify?
You can get that information directly
through the SOP's 3D procedures
that we already have.
So.
(attendees chattering)
- I'm not going to stop.
I'm here to teach you. (chuckles)
(Salih clears throat)
With the AWS MCP in place, we
wanna switch to 10% into 90%,
so you can have
deployment-ready applications
through the agentic IDs.
If you walk around,
you will see this ghost sign
all around and that is Kiro.
With that, we are committing
to build an application through
agentic workflows as well.
We are giving you success
rate of more than 90%
and it brings the best
practices automatically for you.
And one important point is,
with large language models,
there's always this cutoff date
and one of the solutions to that
was actually the MCP servers.
Thanks to the AWS MCP,
now you will know that you
get the latest version of it,
you get all the security-related
information as well.
So, you know in case
you're frontend developers like me,
I have been building
frontend apps for 10 years
before I joined AWS,
and for me, AWS is still a new
role that I learn every day.
And if you're coming from a world like me,
it allows you to move faster
and learn better as well.
But of course, like every one of you do,
do not push the code from
AI into the production.
So, what do we offer
from the SOP perspective for Amplify?
From the Amplify perspective,
we have three important
SOPs that you can use.
One of them is the frontend
MCP that is giving you a chance
to use the frontend libraries of Amplify
to connect with the backend
structure that you build.
The second one is the backend one.
Building backend with Amplify can be easy
but also complicated at the same time.
People ask a lot of questions
on how to do complicated data operations.
Now, thanks to the MCP,
you can actually build these operations
by telling the AI on how
to do it and what to do it,
or even ask to learn or get
the documentation as well.
You don't have to let agent do its tricks.
You can just ask agent to
bring you the information.
You will be still the person to open this.
Because again, these are your tools
and it depends on you on how
you want to use these tools.
And we also have the deployment pipeline.
For Amplify, we have something
we call Amplify hosting
which again, you will see in a second.
Amplify hosting is there for you
to deploy your frontend application easily
without touching any
additional AWS services.
We all know CloudFront S3
works really fine and all,
but if you come from frontend world,
when you jump to the AWS console,
it's a scary time for you.
You know that like there are
hundreds of things writing off
and you don't know which one to click.
And we are all afraid of
paying thousands of dollars
by making a simple click mistake.
That is why these tools that allow you
to have that knowledge (audio
breaks) or this fear as well.
(attendees chattering)
- I was about to rap down
the trademark. (chuckles)
All right.
So, we have the demo.
And today, what we are going to build
is I'm going to show you
two apps that I built.
One is the app
that's showcasing what we have
built in 2025 with Amplify.
And the second thing is
I was talking to Mark
about like how to communicate
with people during re:Invent
and I thought of bringing
the maps of re:Invent
and just giving people a
chance to share their location
for a certain time period
so others can see if they can find them
and ask them questions.
It's not like they dock their location,
it's actually you share where you are
so people can find you
and ask your questions.
So, with that, I will
(attendees chattering)
- go back to the demo.
- And I'm really curious how
it's going to work with this
and the coding.
(attendees chattering)
- [Salih] First question,
can everyone read this?
Everything good on the backside?
Perfect.
So, this is the first
application that I built.
This application is the showcase app.
But the apple of my eye
is the map-face-meetup that I call.
So, let's run this application.
To run the application, this
is a simple React application.
So, what I'm going to do
is I will just do npm run dev, run dev.
And this will just run
my application locally
so we will see how it
looks like with mock data.
So, I will go back, open up my window.
(attendees clapping)
And thank you very much.
And 5371, I think it
was, or no, it's 8081.
All right.
(attendees chattering)
- [Salih] 8081. All right.
So, this is a very basic
application that I built.
It has the sign in and sign up flows
And like I can just add my...
(attendees chattering)
- [Salih] This is totally random stuff
and like just shouldn't
connect to the backend yet.
Let me check it really quickly.
(attendees chattering)
- [Salih] The goal of
this application is...
Actually, let me show you the video
so we can build it together.
(attendees chattering)
- [Salih] No, the goal of this application
is to showcase your real time,
the file upload mechanism
and actually just
everything that you would do
with authentication and so on,
including the pipelines
(attendee laughing)
that you would normally do with functions
and everything else as well.
So, I will do one more npm run dev.
(attendee laughing)
And I would hope that demo gods
would allow me to showcase you this thing.
I have a working version of it
but I really want to build this with you.
So, let's say that this
is my name, this is this.
All right, so this is how it looks like.
So, this is the map that you
have probably seen around
and this is the expo hall map
as well that I found online.
I hope it's correct.
So, what you will do is you can click here
and you can say that I
will be at the AWS Village.
You can select the
services that you know fine
like CloudFront, for example,
edit in a picture, and
it will show a marker
and you will automatically
see the other people
are going to automatically see
how it will look like as well.
So, to turn this mock data into real data,
I prepared some prompts
and I want to take you through the prompt
and tell you a few trips
and tricks to build your applications
through prompts as well.
The first thing that I wanna
tell you is creating a prompt.
Like we will have a one single prompt
just for the sake of
making it run everything.
But first of all, never have
a full prompt like this.
Split it up into multiple ones.
Agents are like your kids,
you have to tell them
exactly what they need
or what they need to do.
They will say no in the beginning
because again, they
will ask more questions.
But later on, it will come
to the place that you want it to be.
In here, I gave them, I said,
use Amplify Gen 2
and use AWS MCP server
that I have mentioned today
that we have released to
build this application.
I added an application overview
and I added some like backend requirements
on like what to do for URLs,
the marker, basically for everything.
we have Lambda triggers so I don't need
to do the email confirmation
for every user that I have created.
Every single detail that
I have here is there
so I can let this thing know
that it needs to do a proper
implementation for this.
With everything in place, what I will do
is I will add even one point here extra
and say that like make sure
you remove the mock data
and actually use the real data at the end.
(attendees chattering)
- [Salih] I don't want to
keep you on hold. (laughs)
That's why like, I also want
to talk at the same time.
In here, I was like,
you don't have to make things complicated.
You can just say,
(attendees chattering)
- [Salih] so like you can just simply say
what you need in one way
and it's important
(faintly speaks) numbered
so it knows what is the most important
and what is the structure as well.
(Salih faintly speaks)
In place.
I will just copy and paste this thing.
It's touching my lips now. I
feel uncomfortable. (laughs)
Really, like it's...
Okay.
Maybe this is better.
But then this way, it
feels super interesting.
You hear me good, right?
Yeah, this is how I drink my tea.
So, I started the session, right?
What it does is it takes everything
and first, it gets
through the application.
It tries to understand
what it needs to do.
For this, we have something
we call in cure streaming files.
Stream files are given
information about your application
to the agents so they don't
need to read every single file
but they would have an understanding
of what they need to do.
And in here, it reads everything,
it checks most clients
so it knows what it needs to change
and what it needs to
remove later on as well.
So, next thing that I wanna show is,
as you see, it calls something
called sop over there.
This sop is one of these profiles
or procedures that is allowing you
to build these applications.
And in here, we have Amplify
backend implementation one
that I had mentioned earlier on
and it is calling them directly.
So, I will just call it,
it will get that information
and showcases directly.
Like I said, we also have the frontend
for the frontend libraries.
We also have the deployment
for deployment part of things as well.
It might need to call
some AWS CLI as well.
Then, it will call AWS
tool inside it as well.
How many of you have not
heard of MCP servers before?
(attendees chattering)
- [Salih] Okay.
For the few folks, I want
to give a very basic example
that everyone gives me as well.
MCP server...
(attendees chattering)
- [Salih] Is it for me? Okay.
MCP servers are basically universal buses
for your agents to get information
in the most efficient way possible.
This allows you
to get the latest information
from a third party
or official party immediate.
Earlier on, we needed to do,
for example, vector database and so on
to bring these informations.
But MCP changes a way
that we build things.
It's not also the lifesaver thing.
Like you shouldn't put
your very delicate data
to the MCP as well. (chuckles)
It's not secure.
It's basically allowing you
to expand the knowledge.
So, large language models cut off date
doesn't mean to you at
the end because of this.
Anyway, we are creating this stuff.
In the meantime, it does that.
I wanna also showcase
the other application
that we have built
and I wanna showcase what we
have built in Amplify in 2025.
How many of you have built an application
with Amplify Gen 2 before?
Nice. All right.
So, let's showcase from there.
I will say I trust you,
you can do this thing.
(attendees chattering)
- [Salih] And I will go back.
So, for building an Amplify application,
(attendees chattering)
- [Salih] when this is
bigger is more visible.
For building an Amplify application,
you have to initialize
the app by installing,
by saying NPM create Amplify,
and this will create this
Amplify folder that you see here.
From the Amplify perspective,
the most important one
is the backend.ts file that we have here.
The backend.ts file keeps the
infrastructure information
that you need about
Amplify or overall AWS.
And you can add any feature
or any service that you want
in the human readable way
like auth, storage, and so on.
And to build them, you need
to create an auth folder
or storage folder, or any
folder that you want to build
with the service that you want.
And these things will allow you
to just get these all together,
make a composition of your
infrastructure directly.
For example, for authentication,
we say I have the email authentication
and I want to have a
multi-factor authentication
because we released it this
year as well with email.
To use the multi-factor
authentication, Cognito asks you
to have a phone number
alongside it as well.
So, you have to have it too.
And the sender of the email
to get the confirmation is
like one email that I have.
And from the storage
perspective, it's just an image,
and we will showcase how the
storage browser works as well.
In here, we define the
storage as the name.
The name defines the
beginning part of your bucket
because S3, as you know,
has universal naming.
So, it needs to be unique.
And we have the rules for
public, protected and private.
Private is for you.
Protected is for everyone authenticated
and public is for everyone.
With this in place, let me
showcase how they look like.
So, we have this application,
we have the web storage, email MFA,
and web authentication to
showcase everything to you.
So, first of all, let me show
the authentication workflow.
With authentication workflow in place,
I will showcase the Passkey.
Passkey is the new way
of authenticating through your biometrics.
If your platform supports through camera,
you can do facial recognition,
finger recognition,
whatever you find useful,
you can do it that way.
How we do it is through two things.
You can have your custom name
or we have a ready-to-use UI
component called authenticator.
An authenticator
basically looks like this.
We have the sign in
and create account so you
can just create an account.
I will just use my burner account
because my Amazon email didn't work
so I will use the other one.
(keys clacking)
So, it will automatically
send a confirmation email.
Now, I will read the
confirmation email quickly.
And with the confirmation email,
I will be able to log in and
do everything that I need.
So, let me use that one very quickly.
I know I can trust you
but I still want to make sure
that (chuckles) I have
the right information.
All right, so let's go back to the demo.
So, I have my code in place,
right, and I'm confirming that.
And once I confirm that now I'm inside
and I have my email and so on.
To register new Passkey,
we have directly APIs,
directly functions that you
can call from our libraries.
So, I click here
and it'll automatically
showcase the email address.
And once I selected the profile,
it will directly edit on Chrome.
So, if I sign out now and go
back to sign in with Passkey
and click on this button,
it will show me that.
And when I use my finger,
it will allow me to log in.
So, this was more
or less the Passkey
approach with biometrics.
The second one that I wanna showcase
is in the meantime, I
wanna check out the...
And this thing is, it is
reading every information.
Another one that I wanna
showcase is the storage browser.
Storage browser is a plugin
and use kind of component that
like we have here as well.
This allows you to use
S3 without extra hustle.
We have UI components directly you can use
with the structure that you have built.
For example, in the protected one,
like we have nothing here,
I can just upload an image
by dropping, something I
will just drop very quickly.
- Okay.
- Tss, tss, tss.
(attendees chattering)
- [Salih] All right,
let's go back to demo.
So, you can see that
like, I put an image here
and I can just click on the Upload button.
Once I click on the Upload button,
I can go back to the protected
and I can, for example,
display the image that has been created.
I can click on Download
to be able to download the
directly, like it is here.
I can also do simple operations
like deleting and so on as well.
With all of these,
imagine you can just do
it with one line of code.
You don't need to think about how to do it
and what to do it.
Everything is happening
through Amplify's way
of building apps, which
is, let me go back,
which is through the
amplify_outputs.json file here.
It keeps all the information that we need
and it allows us to share this
through the components as well.
But this is not it.
We have more things to showcase.
In the meantime, other thing works.
And I wanna showcase
the multi-factor authentication as well.
Last year, we have announced the TOTP.
So, you can use the authenticator apps
like Google Authenticator
and Authy, and so on.
And you can enable it
with one click or one call to the APIs.
And this way, now if I
sign out and if I sign in,
(keys clacking)
now it will ask for a
confirmation code to me.
And the confirmation code should
be coming to here as well.
Yeah, sure, sure.
Yeah, the confirmation
code is here as well.
So, I can click, close it, go
back, and paste this one here.
So, if I confirm now
I have the multi-factor
authen (audio breaks)
For all of these, what
we did was two things.
One was calling the library
like from the frontend.
And second thing
was you have seen the
authentication workflow, right?
Adding this information
about the auth here was the way to go.
Like adding this true
(audio breaks) to go.
Let's do a time check. All right.
So, we have showcased like multi-factor,
we have showcased the storage, and so on.
I will take you through the code
but before I do, I want to
check out what we are doing.
It is doing some changes, that's good.
Meanwhile it does that,
let's go back and check out the code.
For the storage, for the UI component,
what you need to check out
is how we are using this.
Let me showcase the storage page.
In the storage page, we have
many components that we have,
that we have used like
about the like description,
the storage browser,
and so on and so forth.
This allows us to...
Something's moving forward.
Another one, okay.
So, this allows us to actually
bring in the storage
browser directly into place.
So, start, let me find the code.
It's really hard with the second...
Component.
So, if I go to the demo here,
you have to show.
(attendees chattering)
- [Salih] Yes.
So, everything that we have here,
like we are first
configuring the browser here,
the Amplify here.
Before we use the Amplify libraries,
we have to pass in the
information directly.
The search browser here gets the adapter
to get the authentication,
not only authentication,
but authorization flow work as well.
Search browser works directly
through the UI components
that you have created.
And you can just embed it into anything,
including the card components as well.
And here, you can see that
we have the authenticator.
In case the user is not authenticated,
we don't wanna showcase
them the storage browser.
So, everything can be
through this one line of code
that is coming from the
Amplify UI libraries itself.
All right.
So, let me go back
and in the meantime, what it does,
I wanna showcase you one last thing
and how we have deployed it,
how AWS Amplify hosting works.
And this year, we also
announced rough support
which will allow you to have
firewall mechanism easier.
So, let's go back
and let me again, go for a moment,
so I can log in
really quickly.
All right.
All right. So, let me go back to demo.
So, in the AWS Amplify,
if you go to AWS Amplify,
you will see either an empty page,
in case you didn't do it,
or every application
that you have created.
For Amplify, I've showcased,
we have this application in place.
Everything that I've shown you
was out of the deployment stuff,
so I didn't use the local version for it.
So, you can see this is the real one.
So, you can see that you can
see the previous deployments,
the statuses, the problems
that happen with them.
Also for hosting, you can
have many different approaches
and one of them is the firewall.
With this one click here,
now you can have rough support directly
so you can prevent additional
attacks, and so on, to happen
to your Amplify frontend
applications with the single click.
It allows you to protect yourself
from the common
vulnerabilities automatically,
malicious actors.
For example, someone might try
to just send a user agent call
like my user agent or something,
and if it port,
it will automatically trigger
backend calls directly.
And of course, block IP
addresses to (audio breaks)
We did see what we are doing. Still...
(attendees chattering)
- Let's...
- I'm very happy that Salih
could actually do a live demo one-handed
with a mic holding in the other hand.
I don't know if I would've dare to try.
So, what you could see
is that there was a lot
of complex features like
Passkey, storage browser,
web application firewall,
all kinds of things.
But the amount of code
necessary was like in the 20s
of lines of code instead of hundreds.
If you try to do a Boto3 application
with all the SDK codes,
and because it's so little code necessary
and we can guide the AI
to actually use those few
pieces ready-made components,
it is much easier to review.
I mean, I don't know if
you have seen a 600 line PR
on GitHub with just a ship it underneath
and a 10-line request that
got like 10 comments on it.
But that's where we are.
So, you see like hundreds of lines of code
and at some point, you
say, yeah, okay, go ahead.
Okay, so for 2026,
this is something that
we plan for Amplify.
So, first and foremost,
we want to get deeper
integration with CDK.
That is also because CDK
and Amplify are in one team underneath me.
And what we want to have
is that you have more escape
patches that you can use,
more constructs that you can use,
more components within AWS
without having to do custom.
And if you think about a framework,
usually frameworks have a certain limit
and then you're stuck.
If you want to do something custom,
you need to do a lot
of handstands to do it.
But in our case,
we actually want to give
you the full power of AWS
but with everything with sensible defaults
that most of you need, like
we can cater to the 95%
and the 5% should still have a good time
to actually escape where they need to go.
Amplify libraries, working
with any other IaC platform
is something that we have in mind.
If you have created your stuff
with Terraform beforehand,
I don't mind, that's fine,
but Amplify should be able
to recognize what infrastructure there is
and actually apply that.
And we would like to go even deeper
on integration with other AI tools.
And because we are an
open source framework,
please reach out over
GitHub, over Discord,
to tell us what you need for
your application development.
And the last but not least,
the database MCP is part of my teams.
We will get more and
more deep SOPs in there
to actually help you
to get things out life
as quickly as possible.
So.
(attendees chattering)
There you go. So, okay.
So, please reach out to us,
the Amplify documentation on GitHub.
If you really want to give us feedback,
if you have feature requests,
please, please, please give them to us.
And on Amplify Discord
to really have conversation
with my team directly.
And at the end of this talk,
I would really like to ask
you to also go to that survey.
We would like to know a little bit better
on how you use IaC, what
you actually demand there,
how your experience is using it,
and what you can do to improve it further.
So, CDK and cloud formation,
we are all trying to get
things forward for you
so that you can have a good time.
And let's see if the
application now is deployed.
- Almost there.
- Okay, we are almost there.
I know with a lot of setbacks, and so on,
it was a very interesting session.
But thanks for sticking
around. Thanks for being here.
For us, it's really important
that we tell you like everything
that we have done for re:Invent,
not only re:Invent, but
also for Amplify as well.
Amplify is one of those
I would say services
that is like very close to my heart
and I'm really happy
that we can showcase what
we have built around it.
So, right now, it says
it built everything.
It actually deleted the
mock files and so on.
So, let's see if
everything is working fine.
We will start off with,
I hope with a proper sign in flow.
Then, afterwards, we will let the marker.
And if it works, that will be great.
If it doesn't, then I will share
the code with you later on.
I will open source it hopefully
so you can try it yourself as well.
All right, so everything
is in place. Let's go.
Let's create a new user.
(object thuds)
(attendees chattering)
- [Salih] So, like first
thing that people see
is it is directly say that, okay,
the account is created,
everything place this.
So, once the account is created,
it will send an information, and so on.
But I didn't want this, I
actually wanted it to skip it.
So, you can add this flow
directly into it as well.
And it should have. But let's see.
So, let's see what it did for Amplify.
Yeah, for the pre-sign up,
we have everything in place.
So, maybe it was just a simple error.
Let's see how we can log in.
There's already a signing user. I know.
Let me in.
All right, let's do one more
round and we will be good.
Let's see if we can see the
problem and fix it immediately.
So, right now,
what it does is it actually
confirm user and everything,
but it is not allowing to move forward.
So, the issue might be
around (faintly speaks)
the auth flow, the auth component.
And once (faintly speaks) directly.
It will check directly the
state, which is your state,
use auth is controlling the state
for the authentication for the app
and it uploads everything
and checks out run build.
You can see
that for every change that
it does, it permits stuff.
This is what I tell them to do,
- Sounds awful.
- tell it to do so it can know
what I have changed and so on as well.
(mic thuds)
And once everything in
place, we will continue.
This is also not work.
- [Staff] It keeps dropping out.
(audio breaks)
- [Staff] Sorry, everybody.
We're working on the problem.
(Salih chuckles)
- [Salih] This might be the only station
in re:Invent history
to have five or six different
(laughs) microphones in place.
(staff faintly speaking)
- Yeah.
All right, we are like, we started off.
Let me open up the DevConnect here.
Let me to refresh and log in.
(keys clacking)
Come on.
I will just do one more thing.
If it doesn't work, I will cheat.
And I already have a deployed version.
I will just showcase you that one.
(keys clacking)
Yes.
So, we logged in
and once we logged in, the
next thing that we will do
is to like add a location here.
I will say expo at the Venetian.
(keys clacking)
(Salih fantly speaking)
I will just say, for example,
I'm an expert in like API gateway,
it will add the user directly.
And you can see that
we have something here.
You can also upload images too.
So, I can just click on here
and say again,
Aria, like I stay at Aria,
so I will just write Aria.
And say ECS.
And no worries at all.
And I will just select in
image that is showing me.
And I will just upload that image.
And once that image is
uploaded, you can see
that it actually brought
everything together so it cascaded.
And when I come in,
you can see that both of
the markers has changed
because I added my image.
And when I create a new user,
it will showcase the others as well.
So, demo worked.
The storage happened, everything.
And we can slowly take time (audio breaks)
everyone sticking (audio breaks)